hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter nine of peter singer's book the
most good you can do
is titled altruism and happiness
and the key question that's coming
up here is are effective altruists
making sacrifices that then make them
unhappy and the answer is no but it's
not a simple
no he begins by saying when people learn
what effect effective altruists have
done they often wonder what would lead
someone
to make so great a sacrifice for
a stranger but then he observes many
effective altruists
don't see what they're doing as a
sacrifice
at all so many of the effective
altruists themselves when you ask them
about that
they say well it's not really a
sacrifice and we
do need to spend a little bit of time
thinking about what
constitutes a sacrifice and our
attitudes
about sacrificing and morality
there's another question that comes up
towards the
end of the chapter that we definitely
need to take a look at because this is a
perennial issue
that pops up over and over and over
again
whenever we frame things in terms of
altruism on the one
hand and egoism on the other and view
them as opposites
so if these effective altruists aren't
really making sacrifices and they're
getting
something out of it themselves doesn't
that mean that they're not
you know making sacrifices and they're
not altruist then because
you know sacrificing your own interest
for that of the other
that's what's definitive about altruism
as opposed to
egoism and that's actually a very
wrong-headed point of view
but one that comes up over and over and
over again i'll give you a prime example
of that that's not covered in the book
you know in the last several decades
there has been
a sometimes useful but most of the time
a total distraction
discussion going on in about
aristotelian virtue ethics
and his discussion of friendship you
know in loving the friend
are you really being just egoistic and
actually
aristotle even addresses this in nick
mccain ethics book nine
talking about different kinds of
self-centeredness and
it's been like a total distraction
and waste with a few little nuggets
of wisdom here and there but people get
really obsessed about this
and you know the example that he gives
about thomas hobbes
there's a similar example about abraham
lincoln
you know so this is an issue that keeps
coming up over and over again is a
person an egoist
or an altruist it's you know there's a
divide between them and you can't
possibly
connect the two so this is what the the
chapter is really about and
you know we can we can look at um
what effective altruists actually say so
we should talk about the sacrifice thing
right if we think about in terms of
income money and happiness which is i
think you know
singer is right to focus on this because
a lot of effective altruism
does have to do with how you manage your
your sources of income
what you're doing with your money what
you're spending money on
who you're giving it to to further other
people's
interests needs desires things like that
so
there's a lot of possible different
perspectives or experiences on this and
i think it's good to look at the
examples
that singer uses here because they show
us how diverse they could be
so he says toby ord originally thought
that living on eighteen thousand pound a
year would be a sacrifice worth making
because of the good he could do with the
income he was foregoing
later he realized it wasn't a sacrifice
at all because his
sense of engagement in making the world
a better place
means far more to him than new gadgets
or a bigger house
right so there's a trade-off happening
and
he thinks that he's just trading off
some of his own happiness for that of
others
it turns out it makes him happier in the
process right because of the sense of
engagement
julia wise sees her ability to save
hundreds of lives as an amazing
opportunity but demands no more of
herself than she can
cheerfully give so she's saying i'm
gonna do as much as i can
while still remaining cheerful about
this
and not starting to get into grudging
right or
resentful behavior ian ross is familiar
with the psychological research about
the hedonic treadmill of consumer
spending
which shows that when we consume more we
enjoy it for a short time but then adapt
to that level
and need to consume still more in order
to maintain our level of enjoyment
so he says while donating doesn't give
him much of a rush he also doesn't think
he's missing out on much because of
being informed
about how our desires and pleasures and
happiness actually work
when it comes to consumer spending or
consumerism in
in general he says i don't want to go
down that path i don't need to
experience that i see other
people doing that and i can draw on
their own negative experiences to see
that i'm not missing
that much charlie bressler the unpaid
executive director of the life
you can save has told me i truly don't
believe in altruism
i believe the life i'm saving is my own
and i should have started out doing this
kind of work much
sooner so lots of different interesting
examples they're not all in it getting
the exact same thing out of it
what is being sacrificed that's that's
the
key thing there in either having less
money
making less money right and therefore
having less money to
spend or to save some people might want
to put money aside
because you know they don't have a
adequate social security net in their
country
like our country doesn't and we have to
you know put things aside for
for retirement uh or face the prospect
of working well into our 70s or 80s
and so you know people um
rightly do want to have some money some
resources right
what's being sacrificed in having less
of that now
think about the word sacrifice what does
that
imply when you make a sacrifice you're
losing something
that otherwise you could make use of you
could enjoy you could
have and typically we talk about
sacrificing
one thing for another if it's a good
sacrifice
the payoff is greater than the
thing that you're losing and we could
talk about this just with money in terms
of saving right
should you save money or should you
spend your money now while you have it
and enjoy yourself
while you're sacrificing present
enjoyment
and present spending for future greater
spending if you're saving your money
aren't you
unless of course inflation destroys it
or something else comes along
but we can talk about all sorts of other
registers it doesn't simply have to be
money versus money
it can be money versus
having enough time to spend time with
those you love
it can be money versus knowing that
you're making a difference
in people's lives overseas it could be
money versus
animal welfare it could be all sorts of
things so what is it actually being
sacrificed
does having money make us happy
so he says to determine whether
effective altruists are making a
sacrifice
we need to look at the chief
determinants of happiness or at least
those that might be affected by the
kinds of choices
effective altruists make and he says
studies of the relationship between
income and happiness or well-being
indicate that for people at low levels
of income
an increase in income does lead to
greater happiness money can buy
happiness
if you're dirt poor right if you are it
can also do it
also if you're in the red if you're deep
in debt like student loan debt is a
prime example
it's holding many people back from
living the kind of lives that they
probably should be able to enjoy but
unfortunately they got saddled with
lots and lots of debt oftentimes without
you know knowing fully what they were
getting into
there's people who are like oh they
should have known everything before they
headed into it and that's really kind of
an uncharitable way
to look at student loan debt um so you
know
for people at low low levels of income
and increase in income does lead to
greater happiness
but once income is sufficient to provide
for one's needs and
a degree of financial security further
increases
tend to taper off they don't produce
they may produce an additional amount of
happiness but not not
that much and you know i don't can't say
this from experience but
between your first million and your 40th
million
the difference is really not that great
not as much as people
would expect unless you're like super
into the numbers and comparing things
with others but
oftentimes that takes you down all sorts
of rabbit holes of envy
and greed and unhappiness and conflict
so you know there's other ways to boost
one's one's happiness um and
there's some some interesting results
here that we don't need to really
go through but the idea that um
living on low income is going to make
your life a misery turns out to be
largely unfounded he says perhaps we
imagine money is important to our
well-being because we need money to buy
consumer goods right so maybe that would
actually
make us happier buying things as he says
has become an obsession that beckons us
away from
what really advances our well-being and
he's got this
great example of how many people have
garages
that they can't put their cars in
because the garages are
full of the crap that they have been
buying
and stocking up in their garages
sometimes never using
sometimes just you know pet projects
that they're into or
decorations that'll go up once a year
things like that
if you if you can't this is actually
probably a good measure if you can't put
your car
into the building that was designed to
house your car
there's something off something going on
there right something that's that's
off about your situation
um and he says despite the fact that the
growth in size of the typical american
home
means that americans today have three
times the amount of space per person
they had in 1950
they still pay a total of 22 billion a
year to rent an
extra storage space are is this making
them happy
the answer is no as a matter of fact it
may actually
correlate to reduced happiness so
buying consumer goods is not the way to
make people happy but interestingly as
they point out
using our money using our resources to
make other people
less miserable to alleviate suffering or
to make them happier
does tend to make us happy as
human beings and he talks about an
interesting experiment here
um you know and surveying and stuff like
that
so the the point of this is there's a
positive correlation
between having donated to charity and
being at a higher level
of happiness and he says this this shows
correlation not causation
it seems that the causation can run both
ways because people who
are happy are more likely to give to
help others
and you know this leads to a positive
feedback loop so one way to actually
have a happier life is to have some sort
of role
in other people's happiness right
um so that you know that's an
interesting set of
issues when it comes to money we could
also apply some of this perhaps to time
singer also talks about organ donation
and this is a good one because
okay you give your money away that's
that's that's outside of yourself right
i mean sometimes we feel like our money
is us
or our possessions are us but that's a
mistake but if i give away
a kidney or you know some of my blood
or you know some bone marrow or liver
tissue or something like that
i'm literally giving a piece of myself
to somebody
else and you know consider cases where
people do this
without it going to a family member they
they're like listen this is just a good
thing to do there's not enough of these
organs around
i'm a viable donor i'm going to give a
kidney i can live with with one kidney
somebody else could use that kidney
wouldn't that be a
wonderful gift and so he
says you know this is actually a huge
investment um
taking having surgery taking time off to
recover accepting
a degree of risk to one's long-term
health and longevity
all for a complete stranger isn't that a
sacrifice lenny says the evidence shows
that it's not
in in a study seven people who gave
non-directed organ donations
six kidney donors and one a liver
segment were interviewed three months
after their donation now this is a small
study right but
we can draw something from it three of
them had met the recipients and found
this a satisfying experience the other
four
uh remained anonymous but were pleased
with what they did none experienced
psychological
problems and their their they had an
overall
enhanced self-esteem and greater degree
of happiness
afterwards and then this is where he
talks about let's talk
think about self-esteem so it says
self-esteem is an important component of
happiness
i think that's completely right you can
have as much money as you want
you can have as much power as you want
you can be a celebrity
these external goods as we call them in
philosophy you can also have a beautiful
body
you can be in peak health and if you
don't have self-esteem
all of that can just be ways in which
you feel like your life sucks
right if you if you don't have good
relationships with other people
even if you do have good relationships
with other people who like you and you
don't have self-esteem
that can be problematic so he talks
about richard
kirschen this this canadian philosopher
who's developed a concept of
reasonable self-esteem now that's an
important point there
reasonable there's some people who have
you know high degree of self-esteem
and probably shouldn't they are vain
egotistical
jerkish people who think that they're
way more important than others that's
not reasonable
self-esteem reasonable self-esteem is
based on
a you know accurate self-assessment
and he says that this fits particularly
well with the mindset of effective
altruists
um he begins with the concept of a
reasonable person a person who's
defining commitment is to have
reasonable beliefs about the world
what is in his his or her interests
about what they ought to do
and so that is you know quite important
um and now here's where it gets back to
this issue of altruism
it says at the core of the reasonable
person's ethical life
according to krakeshan is a recognition
that others are
like us and therefore in some sense
their lives and their well-being matter
as much as our own
so the reasonable person cannot have
self-esteem
while ignoring the interests of others
whose well-being she recognizes as being
equally significant the most solid basis
for self-esteem
is to live an ethical life a life in
which one contributes to the greatest
possible extent
to making the world a better place so
you know in a way this can foster your
self-esteem but it's also something that
flows
out of genuine self-esteem
as well so self-esteem is connected with
doing good for others
and that leads to happiness not just for
those others but also for the
effective altruists so recognition of
others as
valuable is quite important now this
this brings us back to the key question
that was asked a little bit earlier
he says if effective altruists are not
making a sacrifice do they deserve to be
considered altruists
at all and here's where we have to be
really really careful
what does it mean to be altruistic how
should we characterize it
if we characterize it solely in
opposition to
egoism and then you know
whether we value egoism or value
altruism
we're going to get things wrong because
then we say
the only time that you're really being
altruistic
is when you sacrifice your own personal
interests your happiness
your needs your desires for that
of the other singer says that's a
mistake
what it takes to be an altruist is to be
concerned with the other it doesn't mean
necessarily that you have to sacrifice
your own interest
that is actually a mistaken conception
of altruism probably who might even say
in many cases pathological
conception of altruism and
you know it's possible in many cases to
do things that are beneficial both for
the self
and the other brought up you know
aristotle as an example in in a good
friendship
you are enjoying yourself the friend is
enjoying themselves you're both you know
fulfilling each other's needs
um it's not as if you say oh i'm only a
good friend
if i place your needs so far above my
own that i
don't attend to my own needs at all
aristotle would say that's just stupid
that's not being a good friend at all
that you're being a pain in the butt to
your friend over there
with your whining and misery and oh i'm
making all these sacrifices for you here
that's actually a
going off the path being other centered
is what makes you altruistic
caring for them thinking about how it's
going to
affect them and so you know he's got
some interesting examples here
uh with the the first conception you
know the rich man who does as jesus
tells them selling all he has and giving
proceeds to the poor
he would still not be an altruist
because he was asking jesus what he must
do to inherit
eternal life right and so singer says
listen we don't have to make
self-sacrifice a necessary element of
altruism
we regard people as altruists because of
the kind of interest they have
rather than because they're sacrificing
their interests and he gives this
example
of hobbes who very famously preached an
egoistic philosophy
and you know albeit with some
qualifications
gave to a beggar and people are like you
say you're an egoist and yet you're
giving to a beggar
curious you know to use the old the meme
that's now become almost uh
a cliche and hob says no i
i like giving to this beggar it makes me
happy to do so
so you know while it is in fact making
the beggar happy
it's also making me happy there's a
similar story about
whether it happened or not but abraham
lincoln's saving
some you know uh pigs from from dying
you know
while i didn't want to hear the squeals
of the the dying pigs and the you know
the sad mom or stuff
stuff like that is this really just
being an egoist no
no the egoist is somebody who typically
doesn't care about other people's
interests and desires except insofar as
it affects them
and acts entirely on that basis the
altruist is merely somebody
who is willing to take other people's
desires satisfactions
sufferings their outcomes into
consideration
as a matter of course and thinks that
that's how we
ought to behave as human beings so
effective altruists are not just
covert egoists um they could be egoistic
to some degree and that's perfectly fine
that doesn't prevent them from being
effective altruists
and that certainly doesn't get in the
way of them being happy
through living a life of effective
altruism
you